well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored only day two of
my return I'm already utterly exhausted
by Harry it doesn't stop does it just
interview after interview after series
after but it's just never ending anyways
venomous Memoir spare or spare me as I
renamed it finally hit the shelves today
between the copies sold by mistake in
Spain the orders posted early by Amazon
the endless press leagues and the
multiple TV interviews there aren't many
surprises left for viewers but the
reviews are in and they're not great for
poor Harry woke Bible the guardian
Savages it as a flawed attempt to
reclaim the narrative which deals in the
tropes of tabloid storytelling even is
it lambastian the New York Times
normally in spasms of ecstasy when
there's a chance to bash Britain says
there's only so many Revelations of
public and stomach I think we may have
exceeded that judging by the groan in my
guts this evening and the latest opinion
polls showed that almost two-thirds of
britons now have a negative view of a
man who until recently was one of the
most popular Royals in the country is it
a record low I'll be surprised the more
he talks the more we Grimace he's a
transatlantic turn off about as popular
as well a frost bitten todger to quote
him tonight's Harry's on the latest leg
of his Royal trashing tour in America
guzzling Tequilas joking about his
favorite sandwich on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert and with his most grisly
and graphic claims already revealed
today's eager readers are feasting on
well stuff like this
at last someone said it was time for the
concert to begin off you go follow your
father
concert par
impossible to believe
even more impossible while it was
actually happening but I saw it with my
own eyes poor gamely nodding to the beat
and tapping his foot
if you want my future forget my past if
you want to get with me better make it
fast
after on the way out there were more
flashes this time the Spice Girls
weren't there to deflect attention it
was just poor and me
why does he sound like Gordon Ramsay
have you noticed the audiobook is very
Gordon Ramsay
but ironically the wannabe which was the
Spice Girls Anthem that's pretty much
what he's become right he's a wannabe
reality star he wants to be a male
Kardashian doesn't he he's now on the
late night talk show circuit in America
guzzling Tequilas and telling stupid
jokes and having the Mickey taken out of
her back corgis he's become just a joke
but he's a senior Royal still an
ambassador for Britain part of one of
the most respected institutions in the
world
now he's just a gossiping gutter snipe
selling out his family to the highest
bidders Harry calls the tabloids in full
disclosure I edited tabloid newspapers
here very proudly for 10 years he calls
tabloids the devil
but it's his smirking face on the cover
of all the U.S tabloids which he's done
interviews with
my story my words the problem is that
Harry's story has more holes than a
trumpet he rails against the tabloids
whilst tossing them lurid stories about
sex drugs frostbitten todgers and family
dramas to sell copies of his book about
mounting older women around the back of
pubs
about his brother being circumcised
he's the poster boy for privacy he's
betrayed the privacy of his closest
Family the truth the real truth not his
my truth is that Harry doesn't have a
problem with the press his problem is
not being able to control the Press
Harry has gambled everything on This
Bitter attempt to bully the media and
the public and his own family into
believing his version of history but
unlike the growing list of media Devils
that he sold his own soul to we're just
not buying it